ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE SERGEANT
AT ARMS WILL PREPARE THE CHAMBER
AND BRING IN THE ABSA MEMBERS
AND THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL
I AGREE ARE CURRY. A RAM DEALER
. BARRICADE HAN BENNETT BERMAN
BIGELOW BLOOM BURNER **** BATH
BONTA BRIAN CALDERONE RIO SERVAN
TESTS CHEN SCHORI JULIE COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DAILY DAVIES
FLORA LONGER FRIEDMAN GABRIEL
GALLAGHER CHRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIBSON GRAY
GRAYSON HOLDEN- WHEN JOHN SAWYER
KALRA KYLIE LACKEY LEE LEVIN.
LOW MAIN SHINE MATHIS MAIS
MCCARTY MEDINA MOLLEN MERCY G.
THIS AREA QUINN O'DONNELL
ANDERSON PEACH RESTORES QUIRK
QUIRK SILVA RAMEAU'S RAY IS
LOOSE REBUS ROBERTS RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SOLACE SANTIAGO
SAY ARTURO SMITH SHOWN TEAM
RELATIVE ERRORS VIA FOOD BAR
VOTEL. WALDRON WARD WEBER WICKS
WORD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
THAT OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS. IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND IN
THE GALLERY. PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER. THIS PRAYER WILL BE
OFFERED BY ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
IMAM YASIR KHAN IMAM THIS YEAR.
AND THE NAME OF GOD. THE MOST
GRACIOUS THE MOST MERCIFUL. AT
TIMES WE DO NOT REALIZE HOW WE
HAVE DISTANCED OURSELVES FROM
YOU. NOT ALWAYS ATTENTIVE TO
YOUR VOICE. WE TEND TO WANDER ON
OUR OWN. THEN BY YOUR GRACE YOU
BRING US BACK. WHEN A SENSE OF
ALIENATION SHADOWS ON OUR SOUL
WE FIND OUR DIFFERENCES
DIFFICULT TO BEAR AND MOVE AWAY
FROM EACH OTHER. HELP US TO
OVERCOME OUR HESITANCY. TO
ACCEPT DIVERSITY. GIVE US
LISTENING HARKS WILLING TO GIVE
EACH OTHER TIME AND ATTENTION I
MEAN. YES SIR GUESSER RESERVE
REMAINS STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN DR
WOULD AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE DOCTOR WITH. MEMBERS OF
PLEASE REPEAT AFTER ME I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. EIGHT
ZERO- IT IS A LITTLE. YEAH. YOU
MAY BE SEATED. READING THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY
CHAMBER SACRAMENTO TUESDAY
FEBRUARY THIRD TWENTY TWENTY TWO
THE SAME LIMIT NINE AM THE
AUDIBLE CHRISTOPHER AND WORE THE
SIM WE'VE EVER SEVENTY EIGHT
JUST TO PRESIDING CHIEF CLERK
SHE PROBABLY BEST REINCARNATED
RAMOS MOVES. MR FLOOR SECOND. AT
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS HAVE PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE. INTRODUCTION
REFERENCE THE BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR. THERE ARE NONE
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE. THERE
ARE NONE MOVIE EMOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY SHALL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL. AND MS
RAY YES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTIONS THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE. HELLO SIMPLY MEMBERS JOHN
SAWYER ROAD SEARCHING AND KYLIE
TO SPEAK ON AN ADJOURNMENT IN
MEMORY TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION-SUCH CHUBBY THE ORDER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE ONE EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY. TO ALLOW SPEAKER RENDON
TO HAVE A GUEST AND PHOTOGRAPHER
ON THE FLOOR TODAY. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SPECIAL
GUESTS WITH US IN THE CHAMBER
TODAY MEMBERS. MEMBERS WE HAVE
SPECIAL GUESTS WITH US TO THE
CHAMBER TODAY PLEASE DIRECT YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER. ON BEHALF OF SPEAKER
RENDON WE WELCOME THE AUSTRALIAN
CONSUL GENERAL IN LOS ANGELES
JEANNE DUKE WELCOME CONSUL
GENERAL DO.
M. MEMBERS. MEMBERS
WE HAVE ADDITIONAL GAS WITH US
IN THE ASSEMBLY CHAMBER TODAY ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO
WE WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME HER GAS
WHO ARE SEATED IN THE GALLERY
WELCOME TO MISS RUBY AS GAS.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE. OKAY
CURRENTS AND SENTIMENTS. WELL I
DON'T WANT TO SHOW BE PASS TO
RETAIN ALL RECONSIDERATION FILE
ITEM TO. SHALL. BE CONTINUED.
EVER WE ARE MOVING TO THE
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE.
PASS A RETAINER FIVE ITEM NUMBER
THREE. MEMBERS THIS BRINGS US TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR. HOUSE
RESOLUTION EIGHTY FIVE BY MISTER
BYRD SUSHI THE CORPORATE HOUSE
RESOLUTION EIGHTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MERCY G. AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO JAPANESE
AMERICAN CONCENTRATION CAMPS. MR
MERCER G. EMAIL. THANK YOU MUCH
GOODBYE BECAUSE- I AM PROUD TO
PRESENT HOUSE RESOLUTION EIGHTY
FIVE TO RECOGNIZE THAT TOMORROW
. FEBRUARY NINETEENTH IT'S GOING
TO BE THE EIGHTIETH ANNIVERSARY
OF THE DAY THAT PRESIDENT
FRANKLIN ROOSEVELT ISSUED
EXECUTIVE ORDER NINE ZERO SIX
SIX. WHICH ADDS ALL OF YOU KNOW
LEAD TO THE REMOVAL AND
INCARCERATION OF OVER ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND JAPANESE
AMERICANS LIVING IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THE WEST COAST SOLELY
BECAUSE OF THEIR RACE. WITHOUT
ANY DUE PROCESS OF LAW. AND
WITHOUT ANY EVIDENCE OF TREASON
OR MILITARY NECESSITY. WE KNOW
THAT IN NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
PRESIDENT RONALD REAGAN. SIGN
THE CIVIL LIBERTIES ACT OF
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT. A
HISTORIC CIVIL RIGHTS BILL WHICH
PROVIDED AN APOLOGY ON BEHALF OF
THE NATION AS WELL AS
REPARATIONS TO THE SURVIVORS OF
AMERICA'S CONCENTRATION CAMPS.
IT'S SO GREAT TO SEE OUR GAS
RETURNING TO THIS GALLERY. AND I
WANTED TO SHOW I KNOW THE
SPEAKER IS GOING TO BE
INTRODUCING THEM BUT I WANTED TO
RECOGNIZE WE HAVE. A SURVIVOR OF
THE AMMACHI CAMP. SAM SHIMADA.
AS WELL AS OTHERS FROM THE
JAPANESE AMERICAN CITIZENS
LEAGUE SACRAMENTO IN FLORENCE
AFTERS WELCOME SIR. YOU KNOW WE
KNOW THAT- WITH EVERY PASSING
YEAR. THE ALL OFOUR SURVIVORS
FROM WORLD WAR TWO INCLUDING THE
JAPANESE AMERICAN CAMPS. IT ARE
LEAVING US. SO IT'S YOU KNOW WE
ARE HONORED MR SHIMADA THAT YOU
HAVE MADE THE EFFORT TO JOIN US
I WANTED TO INVITE EVERYONE WORK
WE'RE GOING TO BE GOING TO THE
SOUTH STEPS OF THE CAPITOL.
AFTER SESSION IS ADJOURNED I
FEEL LIKE TO- YOU KNOW SAY
HELLO- TAKE SOME PHOTOS PLEASE
JOIN US- I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT FOR H. R. EIGHTY
FIVE. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER MAHER CG. THE
SURVEY PROVIDE. THANK YOU
SPEAKER. DURING WORLD WAR TWO
MANY JAPANESE AMERICAN FAMILIES
LIVING IN SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
WERE FORCED TO MOVE TO STOCKTON.
ASSEMBLY CENTER LOCATED IN SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS
BEFORE BEING SENT TO PERMANENT.
IN IN INTERNET SITES DURING THE
TIME OF STOCKTON HAD ONE OF THE
LARGEST POPULATION OF JAPANESE
AMERICANS WHICH MAKES THIS EVENT
EVEN MORE TRAGIC. MANY WERE
SUCCESSFUL BUSINESSES OWNERS
PART OF THE COMMUNITY THAT HELP
BILL. AND MANY ARE ALSO GAVE
THEIR LIVES TO WIN THE WAR
UNFORTUNATELY. THIS IS THE KIND
OF RACISM THAT WE STILL SEE
TODAY AGAINST API COMMUNITY THAT
LED TO THIS TRAGEDY. THE
STOCKTON DETENTION FACILITY WAS
FINALLY CLOTHES IN AN OCTOBER
SEVENTEEN NINETEEN FORTY TWO.
BUT IT REMAINS TO THIS DAY A
LANDMARK. TO REMAIN TO REMIND US
OF ALL THE CRUELTY THAT HAPPEN
WHEN ONE GROUP OF PEOPLE
MISTREATS ANOTHER. AND THAT AND
THAT WE MUST DO MORE TO DIVIDE
AND SEPARATE WITH THIS IN MIND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE ALL
HONOR THOSE JAPANESE AMERICANS
AND THEIR LIVES SURVIVORS
FAMILIES TODAY AND BOATING ON
THIS RESOLUTION. THANK YOU
MYSTERY CREW TO A MISTER PATEL
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES. WE'VE HEARD
ME SPEAK BEFORE ABOUT THE FOUR
HUNDRED AND FORTY SECOND
REGIMENTAL COMBAT TEAM THE MOST
HIGHLY DECORATED JAPANESE
AMERICAN ACTUALLY THE ONLY
JAPANESE AMERICAN REGIMENT IN
WORLD WAR TWO INTO. THE EUROPEAN
OPERATION AREA AND- THEY WRE
THE MOST DECORATED ARMY REGIMENT
WORLD WAR TWO NOW THERE'S
ANOTHER SET OF DECIDE JAPANESE
AMERICAN HEROES THAT HISTORY IS
FORGOTTEN. MANY OF THE SAME
PEOPLE THA WERE IN THESE CAMPS
VOLUNTEERED TO GO TO WAR. NOW
THIS PARTICULAR GROUP WERE
INTERPRETERS JAPANESE
INTERPRETERS AND THEY SERVED IN
THE ARMY IN THE PACIFIC. AND
THEY WOULD ACTUALLY NOT ONLY
INTERPRET PRISONERS EXCEPT A-
MAYBE CALL INTO THE JUNGLE
BETWEEN JAPANESE FOXHOLES AND
RESCIND THE CONVERSATIONS THE
GATHERING. VITAL INFORMATION
ABOUT SUPPLIES THE NEXT BATTLE
ABOUT MORALE ESPECIALLY IN ABOUT
FOOD LEVELS BECAUSE THE JAPANESE
IN THOSE JUNGLE START TO DEATH
QUITE OFTEN. THEY BROUGHT BACK
VALUABLE INTELLIGENCE THAT NOT
ONLY SAVE HUNDREDS OF SOLDIERS
LIVES POSSIBLY THOUSANDS THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER. THANK YOU
MICHELLE SAYING NO OTHER MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM
THIS SUMMER SHE SHE WOULD YOU
LIKE COOPERS ON THE HOUSE
RESOLUTION YES PLEASE MEMBERS
THE FIRST ROLE BEFORE CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION CLARK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. WALKERS ON H. R.
EIGHTY FIVE. CO AUTHORS. ON H.
R. EIGHTY FIVE. CLARK WELL.
CLOSE A ROLE THERE SIXTY THREE
CO AUTHORS ADDED. WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON HOUSE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE EYES HAVE
IT THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
THERE IS REWARD PASS RETAINED ON
FILE ITEMS FIVE THROUGH EIGHT ON
SENATE THIRD READING. THERE WAS
A COUPLE OF ANNOUNCEMENTS. TODAY
IS A SEVEN MEMBER PATTERSON'S
BIRTHDAY PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WISHING HIM A HAPPY BIRTHDAY
SEVEN MEMBER PASSED. ALSO
MEMBERS TODAY IS THE LAST DAY
FOR BILLS TO BE INTRODUCED THE
DEATH WILL BE HELD OPENUNTIL
FIVE PM. OR UPON RECEIPT OF THE
LAST BILL FROM LEGISLATIVE
COUNCIL. AND IN THE ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION. THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED. IT'S A CALENDAR.
WHAT A
PASSER TEN ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEMS. ONE CALL HAS
BEEN LIFTED BUT WE ARE MOVING TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED GERMANS IN
MEMORY AND MEMBERS I WOULD ASK
THAT YOU PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS. OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE FLOOR AT THIS TIME.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE FLOOR.
THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS WERE GRANTED PRIOR
PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN
IN MEMORY. ASSEMBLYMEMBER JOHN
SAWYER HE WERE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR A GERMAN IN MEMORY. THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF JOHN AND
JOANNE EVANS OF SAN MATEO
CALIFORNIA. AS YOU KNOW I
REPRESENT SOUTH LOS ANGELES AND
I SINCERELY THANK OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN FRANCISCO FOR ALLOWING
ME TO SPEAK ON THIS A GERMAN. A
GERMAN IN MEMORY TODAY BECAUSE
THIS ONE HITS HOME FOR ME AND
ALL OF MY STAFF. JOANNE WAS NOT
ONLY A DEDICATED WIFE IN A
LOVING GRANDMOTHER BUT YOUR LAND
IS THE MOTHER OF MY LONG TIME
CHIEF OF STAFF COREY I ALLAH.
BORN IN SAN DIEGO IN NINETEEN
FORTY TWO AND RAISED IN OCEAN
BEACH BY CARL AND JEAN DAVIS
JOANNE WAS A BLESSING TO
EVERYONE WHO KNEW HER. SHE
GRADUATED FOUR POINT POINT LOMA
HIGH SCHOOL IN SAN DIEGO STATE
UNIVERSITY WHERE SHE MET THE
LOVE OF HER LIFE STEPHEN EVANS.
WAS STARTED AS A BLIND DATE
BLOOM DIDN'T INTO A LONG TIME
PARTNERSHIP CREATING A LASTING
BOND THAT THRIVED FOR SIXTY
YEARS IN NINETEEN SEVENTY JOANNE
AND STEPHEN WITH THE THREE YOUNG
DAUGHTERS IN TOW FATHER HOME IN
SAN MATTEO WHERE THEY LIVED FOR
MORE THAN THIRTY FIVE YEARS. AS
PARTNERS IN LIFE JOANNE AND
STEPHEN ENJOY CHURCH TRAVELING
AND CREATING EVERLASTING
MEMORIES WITH THE FAMILY THEY
LOVE SO DEARLY. THE DEVICE CHILD
OF GOD JOANNE WAS ORDAINED AS A
DEACON OF FIRST PRESBYTERIAN
CHURCH IN SAN MATEO WAS SHE
FOUND HER MINISTRY BRINGING
COMMUNION AND COMFORT ON TO OUR
FELLOW PRISHIONERS. IN ADDITION
TO SERVING THOSE IN HER OWN
COMMUNITY DURAN SOUGHT TO
PROVIDE BLESSINGS TO OTHERS
WORLDWIDE. DO YOU SERVE THE LORD
AS TO THE TEACHINGS DIRECTOR FOR
COMMUNITY BIBLE STUDY
INTERNATIONAL AND PERSONALLY
SUPPORTED THE EDUCATION OF AN
OPEN. YOUNG WOMAN FROM STUDENT.
AS A TWO TO CAN SO. YOUR ALSO
TWO YEARS A- SUPPORT. PROVIDING
COMFORT AND GUIDANCE TO CANCER
PATIENTS AND THEIR FAMILY.
MEMBERS JOANNE WAS DUE TO
CELEBRATE HER EIGHTIETH BIRTHDAY
TOMORROW. UNFORTUNATELY FOR US
SHE ASCENDED PEACEFULLY UNTO THE
LORD JUST TWO WEEKS AGO
SURROUNDED BY THOSE WHO LOVED
HER MOST ALONGSIDE HER HUSBAND
STEPHEN JOINED TO SURVIVE BY HER
DAUGHTER SHELLY. AND A VERY
BELOVED MEMBER OF OUR CAPITAL
COMMUNITY MRS CORRY EVANS AYALA
JOANNE WAS ALSO BLESSED WITH SIX
GRANDCHILDREN ALEX EVAN JOE
JONATHAN KRISTEN AND- VIVIAN.
IRAN WILL JOIN HER YOUNGEST
DAUGHTER BETH WHO TRAGICALLY
PRECEDED HER PASSING JOANNE'S
RESILIENCE STRENGTH OF CHARACTER
AND UNCONDITIONAL LOVE INSPIRES
IS ALL. AS WE TAKE THIS TIME TO
RECOGNIZE JOANNE'S LIFE WAS ALL
HONOR HER LEGACY BY UPHOLDING
OUR DEDICATION TO SERVING OTHERS
AND MAKING THE MOST OF OUR
EXPERIENCES. FAMILIES AND LOVED
ONES. AND TO COREY AS YOU. AS
YOU WATCH THIS TODAY KNOW THAT
WE LOVE YOU DEARLY AND YOU WILL
ALWAYS BE A PART OF OUR FAMILY
HERE ON THE GREEN CARPET. THANK
YOU MEMBERS FOR JOINING ME IN A
JOURNEY IN MEMORY OF MRS JOANNE
EVANS. AT THE RESTAURANTS OR- MR
MURPHY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN MEMORY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I RISE TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF CONNOR KURAHASHI OF
TORRANCE. CONNOR TRAGICALLY
PASSED AWAY RECENTLY AT THE AGE
OF TWENTY TWO IN A CAR ACCIDENT
. CONNOR WAS A BRIGHT LIGHT IN
THE TAURUS COMMUNITY. THE
TORRANCE KID THROUGH AND THROUGH
. BORN OCTOBER SEVENTH NINETEEN
NINETY NINE AT TORRANCE MEMORIAL
HOSPITAL HE ATTENDED TORAH
SCROLLS VICTOR ELEMENTARY BERLIN
MIDDLE. AND WEST HIGH SCHOOL.
CONNOR WAS ONE OF THOSE KIDS
THAT THE COMMUNITY WILL ALWAYS
REMEMBER. HE WAS THE STUDENT
BODY PRESIDENT. AT WEST HIGH
SCHOOL IN HIS SENIOR YEAR.
ANYONE ON. HE WAS JUST MONTHS
AWAY FROM GRADUATING FROM CAL
POLY CAL POLY POMONA. WITH THEM
A MAJOR IN URBAN AND REGIONAL
PLANNING. WE WERE LOOKING
FORWARD WE HAD BRIGHT HOPES FOR
KONICA HASHI. BUT TRAGICALLY HIS
LIFE WAS CUT MUCH TOO SHORT. HE
IS SURVIVED BY HIS PARENTS. OKAY
AND BRIAN AND A SISTER BAILEY.
AND WILL ALWAYS BE REMEMBERED BY
HIS FAMILY AND THE MANY PEOPLE
THAT HE TOUCHED IN OUR COMMUNITY. THANK YOU MR GARCIA G. AND MR
CRAVIN YOUR RECOGNIZE FOR
GERMANY MEMORY. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER. RENEE I AM THE WAY A
RESIDENT OF ROCKLAND CALIFORNIA
PASSED AWAY ON JANUARY
EIGHTEENTH AT THE AGE OF SEVENTY
NINE THE NATIVISTS OF- IN THE
PHILIPPINES RENE WAS A VETERAN
OF THE UNITED STATES AIRFORCE I
WAS VERY PROUD OF HIS SERVICE TO
OUR COUNTRY. WHEN I WAS A
POSITION OF WORKED MANY YEARS
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
AT A NUMBER OF INSTITUTIONS
THROUGHOUT THE CENTRAL VALLEY HE
RETIRED IN ROCKLAND AND THE
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE TESS HIS
THREE CHILDREN CHERYL CHRISTINE
AND STEPHEN THEIR SPOUSES AND
SEVENTEEN GRANDCHILDREN. RENEE
WAS A DEVOUT CATHOLIC AND VERY
STRONG IN HIS FACE FAITH YOU'LL
BE MISSED VERY MUCH BY HIS
FAMILY AND ALL WHO KNEW HIM
MISTER SPEAKER TODAY I ASKED
THAT THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED ITS SESSION
IN MEMORY. OF RENE E. WAY. THANK
YOU MR CURRENTLY. THANK YOU
MEMBERS PLEASE READ THE NAMES OF
THE DEATHS REPORTED IN THE
JOURNAL ALL REQUESTS RICHARD A
MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED. IN THE JOURNAL SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS MONDAY
FEBRUARY TWENTY FIRST IS THE
PRESIDENT'S DAY HOLIDAY. TUESDAY
FEBRUARY TWENTY SECOND FLOOR
SESSION IS A ONE PM. ALL OF THE
ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE PASS
RETAIN OUR MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED SEEING HEARING OR FOR
THE BUSINESS. I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN MS
BONTA MOVES AND MS CORREO
SECONDS. THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL TUESDAY FEBRUARY
TWENTY SECOND. AT ONE PM WE ARE
EXERT.